I can't walk I did a ring fit stream
yesterday and my legs don't function
yeah you uh what was it because uh you
don't have anywhere to cycle so you're
like I'm going to destroy my legs inside
my house now I don't know I wanted to do
a ring fit stream because I thought ring
fit was a fun game and I actually like I
actually play Ring fit like sometimes
casually right because it's fun and it
is fun yeah they have gamified exercise
Nintendo have done something right
because it was worryingly fun doing
exercise it's a fantastic game yeah
pretty well made
um and I you know I think casually it's
an amazing game I think grinding it is
absolutely [__] stupid I don't think
it's supposed to be grinding I don't
know the game every every time you clear
a stage it's like all right good job man
uh I want to do those cooldown stretches
now and then I have to keep pressing
like no
um so it keeps going but I I don't know
I thought hi I wonder I wonder if I can
burn 1 000 calories on the in-game
um like thing yeah and I wondered how
long that would take and so I thought
how long did it take uh eight hours of
in-game time
are you alive right now well I can't
walk I actually had to get stretched
into the set today no yeah I woke up
with such immense pain because it's all
like no stretches yoga squats
um and I don't know I just thought it
would be fun and I guess I didn't
consider how it would [__] me the
next day
I'm still tired like I slept like nine
hours and I'm still tired no [__] but
was it fun was it fun it was pretty fun
actually yeah it was I mean it's like
ring fit again it's a goaded game like
the music goes unfathomably hard yeah
but for eight hours bro wait hours yeah
it was too long and like I tweeted out
being like Oh yeah I beat I beat I got 1
000 calories in ring fit which by the
way I didn't know the calorie counter
only goes up to 999 and then it doesn't
roll up
[Music]
and uh everyone's like really only 1 000
calories in eight hours I was like look
at how [__] course it's not 1 000
calories like what do you this game is
yeah this is ring fit calories yeah the
game also like [__] lies about how
much you're burning it is because like
my I was wearing two different fitbits
and they both said I burned 5 000
calories by the end of it
um how do you not just like Skin and
Bones bro I'm John what do you mean I
got Junk in this truck a lot of reserves
to work through
um but but yeah I mean if there was a
direction to lie about how many calories
you're burning I think it's better to uh
be inactive for sure about you know
burning less calories than just over a
[Music]
yeah some exercises you're like yeah
this makes sense this wouldn't burn that
many and then when you're doing squat
you're like there's no way this is four
calories I just did twice this feels
like 500 calories like I yeah it's too
much yeah all right the the important
thing is though like okay so it's a game
right did you find a way to like break
the game in any way during those eight
hours to be like um
I'm doing the exercise but I don't feel
like I'm doing the exercise in the way
they're intended is it possible it's a
speed run ring food yeah absolutely so
the trick to speedrunning is I guess the
first level you would get to a ledge and
normally the game will tell you to jump
over it but your character will keep
running yeah and when you're running
you're burning calories all right and
the buy file the quickest way to burn
calories like in real life is to run
yeah it goes up a lot faster so if you
literally just stand in place and jog
for like
two hours right a thousand calories
which I think actually is kind of
accurate I I think if you stood in place
for two hours and jogged you probably
would burn
yeah probably I think around that yeah
that sounds about right maybe maybe not
maybe a little bit less God damn it I
can never get away from the running it's
always the right turns out it always
comes back to the best way to burn
calories is just to run
um or like cycle or do any kind of
cardio intensity exercise yeah uh
running I don't like doing as much
normally because it hurts my legs after
a while I maybe it's because I have
improper running form I don't know but I
that's why I like cycling it's like you
can't [__] it up swimming's also great
too so it looks like actually a full
body which I really enjoy but Japan is
just allergic to pools yeah um this
pool's [__] nowhere unless you pay
like 500 a month for membership yeah
it's pay to win for the swing yeah it's
like even then it's like there's nowhere
like there's one like it's kind of close
to me but it's still just a little bit
inconvenient it's like dude I'm not
gonna go swimming if it's like [__]
so far away yeah exactly something's op
is [__] though yeah yeah but so that's
me getting because I was getting tired
of doing these 12 hour streams where I
just sat there and at the end of the day
I'd be like yeah I'm tired from all that
streaming I look at my Fitbit it's like
you walked 1 000 steps today I'm Jesus
Christ I'll be honest because I tried
streaming a bit more this past month uh
even though most of it is just one
single game yeah which you can probably
guess what it is I'm just like I I it's
just I remember like fin finishing a day
of streaming and some days I'd stream
like you know six hours and I just feel
like wow I've done nothing with today
and uh tomorrow I'm gonna wake up and do
nothing as
do this my mind has literally gone to
much I did it for a week and I'm like
it's because I guess because you have if
you're a full-time streamer yeah you're
like oh this is my this is how I make
money right but I guess for you it's
like well I got obligations I have main
videos to work with no because the thing
is I did feel like I was still okay it's
it's so weird because I'm like I'm
streaming but I'm I always felt like I
was tricking my brain into doing work
when I actually wasn't doing work even
though like I was making money and you
know I was making like second Channel
videos and everything like that uh so
technically I was working but I never
felt like I don't know the work that I
was doing never felt like actual work it
just felt like I was tricking I had
found like a like a [__] work hack to
be like yes I'm actually working on
making money but am I doing anything to
benefit Society I don't know if I I
don't know if I do would you categorize
your normal videos is better you know
what after I didn't but after I've done
streaming for like two weeks I'm like
maybe maybe I'm benefiting
I can't just do like only game streams
like constantly because I just feel like
I'm not doing anything yeah I'm like I
gotta like so this is like you know and
lately I've been trying to
pack more streams in and manage my
schedule which means normally something
needs to get cut out and it's only the
gym yeah so it's like [__] because you
know the time for streaming in Japan uh
again this is like YouTuber talk so I'm
sorry I didn't give a [__] because we we
live in this time zone right the best
time zone to start streaming normally
it's pretty early in the morning for us
or late at night yeah uh and if I start
at like 1pm it's like No One's Gonna
watch yeah because everyone's in every
everyone and every other time zone can't
really watch that so it's kind of like
all right well like [__] you
um so normally if I stop pretty early
but I hate going to the gym at night so
it's like if I want to go to the gym I
go I got to go
you're gonna stream at night go to the
gym in the morning all right so
therefore Stream ring fit and therefore
you fix your own problem do a week's
worth of exercise in one stream that's
not that's not how exciting works I know
that it's not joking
um yeah I mean you know I I just wanted
to do something kind of weird and
contribute to society actually that's a
big part well you're contributing I
informed people how many hours it takes
to burn a thousand calories
there's your contribution to society
absolutely
yeah I think you probably feel that way
about streaming because you you it's not
your full-time like it's not your focus
so I think if you I could I don't think
I could make it my full-time Focus but
after trying it for a week I'm like I
don't know yeah I feel
I it's it's weird right because I you
know there are some there are some
streams where you're like yeah that was
that was really fun and then some of
them you were just like that was really
mind-numbing and I was just playing a
game for eight hours uh didn't really
feel like I did anything uh and I
couldn't imagine doing that every single
day when I wake up and I'm like
don't really have anything to talk about
because all I did was uh play a game for
eight hours uh yeah that was that was my
life the problem is you found the joy of
touching grass
you're also bringing a lot of
um
there's a lot of the streaming when I I
guess it can be it's easier is when you
kind of only get content or you only get
like stuff to talk about from the thing
that you're doing yeah you're not
relying on external things yeah yeah
topics to talk about yeah obviously
there could be things to talk about but
yeah I know that that's one of the
biggest problems of streaming is that it
dedicates so much for your life you
almost get like no other life
experiences yeah yeah because your whole
entire life is just this thing yeah
whereas YouTube right you could I could
make I remember I used to do this uh
back when my videos took a lot less work
and I still thought I was working really
hard because you know you know how it is
like oh my God I work so hard and you're
like I would make like three videos in
one week and I would just do nothing for
three weeks because then I was like oh
this is sick that's what I do right now
Joey's on like special oh my gig up
schedule exactly because you're like man
I worked so hard and you're like wait I
have like four days a week empty I'm
like I don't work that hard yeah I I I
don't know the stuff I'm doing all this
I organize yeah but I mean I guess
you're like nonsense you're working on
stuff like that so that makes sense
right like that's just how your
priorities shift yeah
um but yeah streaming is just so time
and intensive uh dude I don't know man
it's weird